ein tier das ohne sauerstoff überlebt
weil diese sensationelle entdeckung
eines israelischen forschungsteams
verändert unsere sicht auf die existenz
von lebensformen entscheidend und sie
ist ein neues indiz für außerirdisches
leben hinzu kommen weitere spannende
entdeckung auf dem roten planeten selbst
und sie machen potenzielles leben dort
immer wahrscheinlicher klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klicks um
gibt es übrigens auch als podcast für
unterwegs sie links zu spotify und apple
podcasts sind unten in der video
beschreibung so viel steht fest das
leben auf dem mars ist alles andere als
gemütlich die durchschnittstemperatur
beträgt minus 55 grad celsius und es
herrschen extreme staubstürme und eine
wirklich dünne atmosphäre all das führt
dazu dass das leben auf dem mars
ziemlich unbequem wäre dennoch
beherbergt der rote planet wasser und
geht somit als potenzieller heimat von
leben zudem gibt es viele hinweise
darauf dass der mars einst mal an
durchaus lebensfreundlich ort gewesen
sein muss demnach könnten hier vor etwa
vier milliarden jahren temperaturen
geherrscht haben die wasser über lange
zeiträume hinweg flüssig gehalten haben
möglicherweise gab es hier damals sogar
ausgedehnte ozeane
möglich gemacht hat das
höchstwahrscheinlich eine bedeutende
dichtere atmosphäre die einen hohen
anteil an treibhausgasen enthielt da die
sonne in der frühzeit des
planetensystems rund 30 prozent
schwächer strahlte als heute wäre es
ansonsten viel zu kalt für die existenz
von flüssigem wasser gewesen vor zwei
jahren 2018 gab es gleich zwei
spektakuläre entdeckung auf dem markt
zum einen hatte der mars rover curiosity
in dem jahr milliarden altem gestein des
mars organischer materie aufgespürt die
rede ist von sehr einfachen
kohlenstoffverbindungen die hinweise auf
eine lebensfreundliche zeit auf dem
roten planeten geben konkret handelt es
sich bei der entdeckung um aromatische
asiatische und telefonische verbindung
möglicherweise hat es auf dem mars also
1 von mikroben nur so gewimmelt zudem
hat
der nasa rover auch eine
methankonzentration in der maßlos
festgestellt die stark schwankt auf der
erde entsteht methan durch biologische
prozesse beispielsweise wenn rinder ihre
nahrung verdauen und noch immer ist
nicht klar wo das methan auf dem mars
her kommt dann die nächste sensationelle
entdeckung ein italienisches
forschungsteam hatte einen rund 20
kilometer breiten see unter de maistre
smart südpols aufgespürt die ersten
belege für flüssiges wasser auf dem mars
also also aktuell flüssiges wasser der
see befindet sich rund 1,5 kilometer
unter dem eis des maßes und zwar in der
südpolregion des roten planeten planung
ausstrahle
die daten zeigen in dieser abgegrenzte
region dieselben signaturen wie sehen
unter dem eis in polar regionen der erde
und in unterirdischen seen wie
beispielsweise dem lake willens in der
antarktis wimmelt es nur so von mikroben
bedeutet das etwa dass die existenz von
leben auch in diesem gletscher sehen das
maß eine klare sache ist flüssiges
wasser ist schließlich die
grundvoraussetzung für leben so wie wir
es kennen in der südpolregion des roten
planeten ist es allerdings deutlich
kälter als in unterirdischen seen der
erde bei minus 68 grad celsius soll die
temperatur bis jetzt entdeckten mars es
liegen dass das wasser flüssig ist liegt
nach vermutung des forschungsteams an
einem hohen salzgehalt natrium magnesium
und kalium salze die sowieso häufig auf
dem mars anzutreffen sind könnten den
gefrierpunkt des sees deutlich
herabsetzen
eine derart hohe salzkonzentration mache
es für mögliches leben in dem maß wasser
nicht gerade einfach doch ein
ausschlusskriterium ist dies nach
ansicht des forschungsteams nicht denn
auch auf der erde gibt es
mikroorganismen die mit einer hohen salz
oder und säurekonzentration
zurechtkommen so hatte ein spanisches
forschungsteam vor einiger zeit eine
spektakuläre entdeckung an einem der
lebensfeindlichen gebiete der erde
gemacht die rede ist von dem geothermal
gebiet im nordosten äthiopiens dieser
ort wird völlig zurecht auch als ort
ohne wiederkehr oder als eingang zur
hölle bezeichnet wenn in dieser
vulkanlandschaft sprudelt tatsächlich
säure aus dem boden zudem werden hier
die höchsten durchschnittlichen
jahrestemperaturen der erde gemessen
im ersten moment könnte man tatsächlich
denken dass man sich auf einem fremden
planeten befindet die gegend ist umgeben
von aktiven vulkanen und das grundwasser
wird durch magna erhitzt beim aufsteigen
löst das manchmal die 1000 meter dicken
salz und anhydrit schichten mineralien
auf diese lagern sich an der oberfläche
ab und bilden so die salz türme in
kuriosen und verschiedenartigen formen
bei austritt haben die salzwasser
quellen eine temperatur von 100 9 grad
celsius im wasser und den boden liegt
der ph wert unter 1 das bedeutet einen
extrem hohen säuregehalt mit hilfe einer
chemischen analyse an der dna
sequenzierung und der verwendung eines
elektronenmikroskops gelang den
fachleuten die erstaunliche entdeckung
einzellige organismen die hier überleben
und das schon seit vielen hunderttausend
jahr konkret handelt es sich um mikroben
mit der bezeichnung nano a share tor
dazu der astrobiologe verliebte gomez
dies ist eine exotische wirklich extreme
umgebung mit organismen die hohe
temperaturen einen hohen salzgehalt und
einen sehr niedrigen ph-wert aushalten
müssen um zu überleben
diese entdeckung reiht sich in einige
weitere erstaunliche erkenntnisse in
diesem zusammenhang ein
denn auf der erde wurden schon
zahlreiche wirklich denkbar
lebensfeindliche orte aufgespürt wo es
trotz extremer kälte oder hitze von
organismen nur so wie zum beispiel bei
122 grad celsius in heißen quellen und
auch das andere extrem ist möglich
selbst hunderte meter unter dem antrag
des gletschers ist leben möglich und es
wird noch krasser auch im havarierten
kernreaktoren wie tschernobyl wachsen
pilze organismen sind also extrem
widerstands und anpassungsfähig und
somit in der lage auch unter eigentlich
unmöglichen bedingungen zu leben im
klartext heißt das also auch die
uv-strahlung der sonne
die ansonsten leben zerstört könnte
organismen in tiefen gesteinsschichten
des mars nicht erreichen
die wirklich extrem fundorte von
organismen auf der erde sprechen
eindeutig dafür dass es organisches
leben auf dem mars sogar über milliarden
jahre hinweg ausgehalten haben könnte
dazu die wissenschaftlerin barbara
kavala ziehe aus bologna eine
detaillierte untersuchung der merkmale
dieser erstaunlichen region wird unser
verständnis der grenzen des lebens auf
der erde verbessern und für unsere so
nach leben auf dem mars und anderswo im
universum extrem hilfreich sein
hinzu kommt jetzt eine sense and deckung
eines israelischen forschungsteams die
unser verständnis von leben verändert
denn bislang hatten fachleute die regel
aufgestellt das ohne sauerstoff kein
leben existieren kann
doch der quallen artige parasit mit der
bezeichnung henne goya salmi nicola der
vor allem in sachsen vorkommt belehrt
uns eines besseren
denn er benötigt keinen sauerstoff zu
überleben er atmet nicht und ist nicht
vom sauerstoff abhängig das ist wirklich
eine komplett neue erkenntnis denn
bislang kannte man diese fähigkeit nur
von einigen einzellern die in extrem
sauerstoffarme umgebungen existieren
können der kleine fisch parasit der aus
komplex aufgebauten sporen besteht ist
somit also das erste bekannte tier das
keine funktionsfähige mitochondrien
besitzt die so genannten kraftwerke der
zelle sind bei ihm reduziert und auch
die gene die für die funktion der
mitochondrien notwendig sind fehlen
mittendrin sind die energielieferanten
unserer zellen die dafür sorgen das
energiereiche moleküle unter
sauerstoffverbrauch erzeugt werden
können
die energie die dieser winzige
organismus zum leben braucht entzieht
der möglicherweise den laxen dazu nistet
er sich in dem muskelgewebe der fische
ein
doch die fachleute schließen auch nicht
aus dass diese neu entdeckten parasiten
einen sauerstofffreien typ der atmung
besitzen ähnlich wie man es von hier
oben einzellern kennt möglicherweise
verändert diese entdeckung also nicht
nur unsere sicht auf die existenz von
lebensformen sondern bietet uns auch
einen neuen zugang zu außerirdischen
leben bei der suche danach könnte diese
erkenntnis eine völlig neue
herangehensweise bedeuten existieren
derzeit also lebewesen auf dem mars oder
gab es sie zumindest eins dort
auszuschließen ist es ganz und gar nicht
dass der rote planet auch heute noch
lebensform in seinen möglicherweisen
feuchten tiefen beherbergt geologische
merkmale des mars offenbaren der
fachwelt jedenfalls dass auf seiner
oberfläche vor etwa dreieinhalb
milliarden jahren flüssiges wasser zu
finden war dieses versicherte dann im
laufe der zeit in seinen untergrund und
verdunstete ins weltall klar ist
jedenfalls dass zu der zeit in der der
mars lebensfreundliche bedingungen
aufwies das leben auf der erde entstand
hier entwickelten sich also die ersten
einzelligen organismen verlief diese
entwicklung möglicherweise auch parallel
auf dem mars oder kam das leben sogar
vom mars auf der erde sind wir also
selbst aliens marsianer herausfinden
soll dass der mars rover provence im
rahmen der nasa mission mars 2020 der im
juli zu unserem roten nachbar planeten
aufbrechen soll gerade haben die nasa
fachleute seine instrumente im heißen
und kargen südaustralien getestet und
zwar mit erfolg denn fest steht sollen
sie spuren früherer lebewesen im maß an
finden muss ihnen das zuvor auf der erde
gelungen sein deswegen hatte das
australische forschungsteam nachbauten
der originalinstrumente vom präsenz auf
die spurensuche in einem gebirgszug in
der nähe von adelaide geschickt dazu die
astrobiologin bonität die gegend dort
eignet sich sehr gut um forschung zu
betreiben wir auf dem mars es ist ein
trockenes staubiges und windiges gebiet
sehr krank dass eine gute analogie
bietet um wie auf dem mars nach leben zu
suchen die aufgabe war klar definiert
die instrumente sollten in den felsen
die besten stellen identifizieren die
möglicherweise biomarker organische
komponenten oder fossilien von
mikroorganismen enthalten könnten
mit am start war ein röntgen instrument
eine kamera mit hoher auflösung in der
ferne und ein spektrometer das bio
signaturen aufspüren soll um messfehler
auszuschließen müssen verschiedene
instrumente eindeutige hinweise liefern
und genau das passierte die perser
various instrumente konnten über 500
millionen jahre alte spuren des lebens
aufspüren die instrumente haben damit
den test gut bestanden auf dem mars
selbst ist geplant dass der rover nicht
nur zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
raumfahrt gesteinsproben gewinnt die zur
erde gebracht werden sollen auch die
mars oberfläche soll er detaillierte
analysieren ein us forschungsteam hat
jetzt gerade auch noch einmal bestätigt
dass das angepeilte untersuchungsgebiet
auf dem roten planeten gut gewählt ist
im bereich des jesu kraters zeichen sich
nämlich höchstwahrscheinlich reste eines
einstigen flussdeltas ab und das ist für
die suche nach spuren von leben
natürlich äußerst erfolgversprechend
auch modellsimulationen machen große
hoffnung denn sie offenbart dass der
fluss im visier wo krater mögliche
mikrobielle lebensform auf der
marsoberfläche 1 fort getragen haben
könnte und sie sich somit
geschützt unter den sedimenten
abgelagert sein könnten dazu der
forscher macho la porte
es sollen bei der mission die ersten
proben entstehen die für untersuchungen
vom mars zur erde gebracht werden das
ist sehr aufregend denn es könnte sich
damit die chance ergeben einblicke in
die entstehung von leben auf dem anderen
planeten zu gewinnen und somit auch in
die frage was leben überhaupt ist einen
weiteren vielversprechenden ort für die
suche nach leben auf dem mars hat auch
ein us forschungsteam identifiziert die
fachleute hatten merkwürdig helle
regionen auf dem mars mit ähnlich
aussehenden gebieten auf der erde
verglichen und waren dabei zu einem
überraschenden ergebnis gekommen
demnach könnten auf dem mars vor
mehreren hundert millionen jahren heiße
quellen zu finden gewesen sein
die rede ist von dem werntal krater in
der äquatorregion des mars wo helle
elliptische formen zu finden sind
tatsächlich sehen sie aus als sei dort
früher mal wasser aus dem untergrund
aufgetreten hier war wohl möglicherweise
mal ein brocken eingeschlagen der nicht
nur den krater verursacht hat sondern
eben auch wasser freigesetzt haben
könnte
dieser ort wäre nach ansicht des
forschungsteams optimal um nach leben
auf dem mars zu suchen dazu die
wissenschaftlerin jessica bands die an
der studie beteiligt war wenn dies
tatsächlich heiße quellen waren könnte
man durch eine genaue untersuchung vor
ort etwas über die lokale bewohnbarkeit
des mars durch extremo viele
mikroorganismen herausfinden
nicht nur ein guter ort um nach leben
auf dem mars zu suchen sondern auch der
ideale ort für eine menschliche maß
siedlung wurde jetzt von der nasa
identifiziert der mars reconnaissance
orbiter hatte bereits 2011 ein
gigantisches loch an den hängen des
vulkans pavone swans ausgemacht es zeigt
eine extrem mysteriöse maaß schule die
es in sich haben könnte auf dem bild zu
sehen ist ein krater mit einem
durchmesser von etwa 130 metern
in seiner mitte 1 30 meter großes loch
eine öffnung der eingang zu einer
unterirdischen höhle die durch frühere
vulkanische aktivitäten auf dem mars
entstanden sein könnte ähnliche
strukturen wurden bereits auf dem mond
aufgespürt und könnten bei zukünftigen
weltraummissionen eine große rolle
spielen denn als siedlungs standorte
hätten sie für die astronautinnen und
astronauten viele vorteile
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam lover
röhren
orte die vor kosmischer strahlung und
mikrometeoriten weitgehend geschützt
sind sie bieten damit auch sicherer
areale für zukünftige menschliche
siedlungen zudem sind solche massen nach
ansicht der wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler auch für die suche nach
potenziellen lebensspuren sehr
vielversprechend kommt das leben vom
mars mehr zum thema bei astor comics
anklicken anschauen und unbedingt
abonnieren sehr cooler kanal bis dann
bleib dran